say hey i'm back okay
[Music]
hey everyone my name is kelly and i won
the quarantine chef challenge with my
homemade chicken pot pie and today i
have my sidekick back what's your name
i'm doing it dylan and we're gonna make
our own version of hamburger helper
ready yeah we got this yeah give me a
high five oh yeah
so i don't know about you guys but i'm
pretty much sick of cooking so i've been
trying to do
really easy one-pot dinners that use
minimal dishes that still taste good and
have some nutritional benefits for my
little kitties just fyi this is a kid's
knife he can't cut himself
[Music]
we're gonna cook off some of this bacon
yeah i just chopped it up a little bit
we're gonna put it in the pot
i got the carrots oh great
the bacon is cooked i'm gonna remove all
the a tablespoon of this oil and then
we'll saute the onions in that
so dylan's going to come back and show
us how we cut a red bell pepper
hey dylan do you like your vegetables
what's your favorite vegetable
that's a fruit i have a hard time
getting dylan to eat vegetables so i'm
always trying to sneak them in where i
can for this dish i'm choosing to use
carrots and red bell peppers they're
both naturally sweet so it'll go really
well with the base of the dish which is
tomatoes
we're doing it
it's going inside and then we're going
to saute them with the onions and the
carrots in that delicious bacon bed
okay we're just gonna grate in some
garlic now our veggies are softened so
we're gonna add in one pound of lean
ground beef so just break it up with a
spatula and cook it until it's browned
and cooked through about five minutes
and of course to season it with some
salt
now we're going to add some what i call
adult flavors just to kind of elevate
the just a little bit so it's still
something that me and my husband are
excited about but we know the kids will
still eat it so the first thing i'm
going to add is smoked paprika the next
adult flavor i'm adding is double
concentrated tomato paste and let it
cook for like three to five minutes
until it starts to turn into a dark red
color it's gonna give it a really
intense tomatoey flavor and have really
nice umami notes we're adding a can of
petite rice tomatoes with some beef
stock
[Music]
some whole milk
wow
so many meals one pound
of any shape of pasta you like this
smells so good if you had any herbs you
could also add them thyme would be great
in this we're going to garnish it with
parsley later um but feel free to you
know
experiment and see what works for you
can i mix please stir it
good up okay good job
so this is at a low boil i'm just gonna
cover it and cook it for 10 minutes
stirring every three to four minutes
just to make sure nothing is getting
burnt on the bottom the sauce looks so
velvety and creamy and rich and
delicious as the pasta cooked the
starches released and it helped thicken
our sauce okay let's add the cheese i
turned off the heat as we're adding the
cheese and we're just going to let the
residual heat melt it and then we'll
serve it up nicer mom
how in the stir you want sure yeah
yes hey dylan
i love you
what'd you say i love that
okay all the cheese is melted
it's looking velvety it's looking creamy
it's looking delicious um i'm just going
to add a little bit of this bacon
because there's a lot of bacon stir that
in and then i will serve it up to the
boys and see what they think literally
it tastes ten times better than the box
version it's smoky it's creamy it's
cheesy the noodles are perfectly al
dente
this is a home run um i like it
was it delicious yeah can you give me a
thumbs up
is that your thumbs up
alright guys well that is how you make
my one pot homemade hamburger helper it
was easy it came together in under 30
minutes the kids are eating it we're
happy about it and
that's all that matters let me know if
there's anything else you'd like us to
make just comment below and you can
follow me on instagram at kelly m page
mickey findy
you're starting with
what do green vegetables do for you um
it makes me
help and strong healthy and strong yeah
show me your muscle
see those guys
do you want to show them another toy
yeah all right go get another tour to
show your new friends
okay let's taste it
[Music]
i look like i don't like it but i
that's just my face
oh yes
[Music]
you